this is really his first year starting
he just made it to the super bowl you
know
give him more time before you start
saying this and that about him just just
let him be in the moment
you know and right now he's in the super
bowl he's trying to get his first ring
as a starting quarterback in his league
and you know i pray to god it happens
emmanuel sanders on jimmy garoppolo uh
i mean yeah we we respect it we're not
gonna let him have it that's not what we
do i mean we're in the media well and
it's fair
what is the guy gonna do when he hasn't
done anything for the last six quarters
of championship level football right
when you only throw the ball eight times
in this day and age in today's nfl when
you go bob greasy for a championship
game yeah there's going to be questions
about whether or not the team believes
whether or not he can get it done if he
has to get it done and if he's called
upon will he get it done yeah emmanuel
sanders is the second super bowl he's
been in and both times i mean you know
you got to question peyton manning the
first time around too yeah peyton did
not have a good year that year either
but they found a way to win it all right
super bowl bold prediction draft peter
gets the trivia question if he gets it
right he gets the first pick if he gets
it wrong sims gets the first pick either
way i'm sitting here with the third pick
as
usually happens when we do a
three-person draft only three
quarterbacks peter in nfl history have
lost their super bowl debut and later
gone on to win a super bowl name
two of them
three quarterbacks lost their super bowl
debut and then went on to win two of
them no name two names oh name two of
them
um i would say
um
i would say len dawson
you're correct
and i would say one you got it come on
uh got it his name was just mentioned
i don't know there's other ones too that
you got i would say peyton manning
no no he won this oh he won the first
john elway john elway
yeah
john elway he what he lost what was
three three three yeah he lost three
right victim of his own sims wins sims
sims wins because of my incompetence
first pick bold prediction all right i'm
going bold here all right i'm going bold
i'm going nick bose the three sacks in
this game that's both i don't know that
is a bold
i know and that's what that is the super
bowl record right is ely have that uh
you know reggie white had three well and
then yeah and you're right and the uh
coney ealy had it against
carolina right with the broncos game but
i think nick bosa and again i'm not
saying all three of these sacks are
going to be like domination around the
edge and like mahomes is in the middle
of his drop back and getting like
blindsided i think like to what you
mentioned earlier in the show he could
get one two sacks just because mahomes
early on being careful trying to buy
time making sure he sees the field right
and he gets a sack just because of his
pursuit and finally running down mahomes
that way so uh i'm gonna throw that one
out there right right to start my bold
prediction is tevin coleman gets more
carries than rahim mostly
and look i think it's all because what
we were talking about before
kyle shanahan
is going to not be dictated to by what
he just did he is going to look at what
he wants to do
in this next game and i'm not saying
that he even views coleman better than
moster right now i'm saying that i
believe that part of the unexpected
uh is unexpected personnel usage and in
my opinion everybody's expecting mostar
to be the guy and i believe that he's
gonna come back assuming that his
shoulder is okay
uh that tevin coleman's gonna get the
ball more than most her i think that
makes plenty of sense and we've seen
that the 49ers will ride the hot hand
and it just happened that day that the
plants lined up for mostard coleman got
injured and and off it went all right
this is a very bold prediction i'm going
very far out on a limb here this is very
risky for me
the 49ers will not blow a 28 to three
lead that's my prediction
that is a gutsy
gutsy call they actually they actually
made a bet on that and the odds are only
a hundred to one how is it only on the
one first of all you're not gonna build
a 28-3 lead and if they build a 28-3
lead see he's mad that i went there if
you're gonna build a 28-3 lead there's
no way in hell you're going to blow a
28-3 lead not after what happened the
last time that kyle shanahan had a 28-3
lead in the super bowl that was just for
you what a cop-out pick that that's a
cop i mean what i mean that was like as
bad as stats
what color is blue for you than when the
the draft first picked they won't blow a
28-3 lead all right it's been done yes
it has been it has been all right um i'm
gonna
i don't know i i'm gonna say this i'm
not i'm gonna go
you always make me nervous when you
start i know it's nothing four letters
or any bad words so don't worry all
right you hang in there i i'm gonna say
that this is i wanna i don't i don't
know what the highest scoring super bowl
ever is
but i'm gonna say this is one of the
highest scoring super bowls ever i just
think with andy reid shanahan the
weapons at their disposal
uh two weeks of preparation
the more i think about this game like
originally i thought maybe it was going
to be a 28 24
31 27 type game i feel like i the more
the week goes on i i want to say it's
going to be 38 35 or 41 38 almost 49 26
it combined 75 points the last time the
49ers won the super bowl i guess the
chargers
this becomes the highest scoring super
bowl uh in our history
75 that is bolt that's a ball because i
think that the 49ers is going to try to
take air out i don't know the way they
play off that's going to try to take air
out of the balloon the way they play
defense i'm going to try to slow it down
and shorten the game and reduce the
possession yeah i i am you know i i know
i did some being bold it's a bold
prediction draft that's where i'm going
damien williams leads all running backs
in the super bowl in rushing
that's bolt that's bulls that's both
because because in my opinion i think
what the kansas city chiefs are going to
try to do is just what they tried to do
against the tennessee titans play keep
away you know they want to posses
everybody wants to possess the ball and
keep the other team from maximum
possessions but in my opinion i think
damien williams is kind of the secret
weapon on this kansas city chiefs team
yes nobody believes that anybody but
these great speedy wide receivers can do
anything and i think andy reid and eric
b enemy are sitting there saying you
know what we're going to surprise him
we're going to bleed this clock a little
bit and we're going to use damien
williams more than we have
all right my next one and this one may
not be a bold prediction jimmy garoppolo
two
interceptions
here he is negative nancy i'm just
negative
hello
you said both of three sacks that's
negative for patrick mahomes he's not
able to run around yeah well i went
positive on nick well it wasn't negative
matthew will get two interceptions of
jimmy garoppolo is that positive that's
better i like that how about that tyler
matthew will get two interceptions at
jimmy garoppolo okay that's better than
your first one i mean jeez louise was
that horrible but i really do think that
if
now it's all premised on the chiefs
being able to slow down the running game
and forcing jimmy garoppolo to throw but
i'm concerned about
garoppolo i i am until he throws until
they trust him to throw and until he
shows me he can do it i'm going to be
concerned and i think tyron matthew he's
got that troy polomalu quality it would
be fitting paula muller goes in the hall
of fame saturday and tyrant matthew
plays like him on sunday all right all
right i've had enough of your jimmy
garoppolo hey i'm going to counter it
right now jimmy's throwing for 500
49ers win the super bowl jimmy g will be
the mvp that's going to be my next
prediction i am i'm going to go there
okay i'm going to go there even though
nick bose is having three sacks yeah
yeah we know the quarterback always gets
it it doesn't matter i mean unless it
gets like a strip sack fumble or
something like that then maybe that will
change but
all right i mean again this is the bold
prediction draft i could certainly see
to like what both of you been saying
where like kansas city is just going to
sell out to stop the run and just going
to go all right we don't believe jimmy g
can beat us and i think shanahan as
we've talked about before and and andy
reid they have alternative plans okay
well they're doing a little something
different to my run game i wasn't
expecting this all right let me unveil
my passing attack with jimmy garoppolo
so i'm going to throw that out there and
say 49ers win jimmy garoppolo has a huge
day and is the mvp kendrick bourne leads
all receivers in this game in receiving
whoa that's a good one because i think
the speed of kendrick bourne you know
he's the former olympic track guy
what was this thing the long jump maybe
i think it was the long long journey
yeah oh that's marquise goodwin marquis
sorry sorry but ken kendrick bourne is
is a you know he's not tyreek hill yeah
but he's really fast and i think they
end up using his speed and basically
uh that he's gonna be garoppolo's guy in
this game he's gonna have two or three
big catches i think he's well over a
hundred yards he was great in the
divisional round he had three catches
they were all big catches a touchdown a
couple of third down conversions but
they stopped throwing that's the thing
they stopped throwing so how can jimmy
garoppolo be the mvp how can he have all
those guys if they
are able to run the ball that's the
great unknown if they can't run the ball
then all those things happen all right
uh how about this me cole hardman takes
the opening kick off for a touchdown
whoa that's bold that is bolt that is
it's kind of brassy it reminds me of the
tony dungy story from super bowl 41. the
tony amazing
the colts were determined to not let
devin hester
beat them in the the the super bowl with
a touchdown return and so they and he
didn't want to kick the ball
away from him yeah gonna kick away from
him we're not gonna let him beat us and
then the night before the super bowl he
said screw it we're gonna kick it to him
we're gonna take it to him so the bears
had the opening kickoff and they kicked
the ball devin hester and he took a
touchdown
and the colts won the super bowl so what
did dungy do he said he looked one over
to those special teams coaches like all
right no more don't kick it to him again
but miko hardman i mean really he he was
the guy that sparked the comeback the 24
nothing deficit yeah with that return
short field but let's let's see him take
because everybody's gonna be nervous
everybody's gonna be keyed up it's one
of those things where but the problem is
happening the problem is isn't
wishnowski and i wish i had the stats
but isn't he mr he's mr touchback he is
so okay maybe he'll have 109 yard kick
return and it'll be no no no don't take
it out don't take it hey great decision
uh and and you know the super bowl
everything everything changes right it's
that you know maybe the nerves he puts a
few fewer yards on it and uh would you
be a throw up guy before the super bowl
no i haven't thrown up in 18 years since
the last time you had the black and
white cookies it was it's i i have the i
have multiple lifetime seinfeld this is
a great i might have been a throw-up guy
what no
talking about throwing up this is a
breakfast topic people what's the la
when's the last time you threw up and
why day after super bowl 38 the day
after super bowl why you had a few beers
no no i got my son was sick and i caught
it from him but i know it was the day
after that superb that was the last time
you filmed last time oh 18 years ago 16
years ago 16 years ago holy cow why
what's your what is your recipe for not
throwing up it just doesn't happen he's
uh he's got an italian a meatball
he doesn't have it never comes up i know
when to stop eating and i know when to
stop drinking and i don't want to stop
did you know did you know that 25 years
ago this week super bowl week steve
young wins the mvp my assignment for
sports illustrated is to follow him
after the game lee steinberg steve young
me or in this limo and steve young had
like three big gatorades he had been
dehydrated in miami humid night right
and about three minutes into the car
ride he projectile ralph's
all over lee steinberg's shoes that's
amazing okay and then part of the ralph
part of the ralphage goes on my shoes oh
and steinberg vp ralph steinberg has the
best line of the evening he says well
never wash those shoes again yeah i mean
you could probably sell those still on
ebay
exist 25 years ago but i mean if they're
they're probably uh even riper now 25
after 25 years in a bag somewhere the
steve young vomit shoes on that happy
now we're going to take a break
and a vomit peter king's super bowl
prediction no no no
no
l'oreal with that weak first round pick
oh my gosh
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports